(audience cheering)
(laughing)
- You're like,
hold up,
hold up.
It never happened.
- [Ted] These are my pretty shoes.
- Oh my God.
- Those are my really comfortable shoes.
- I am with you.
I literally just found a pair of comfy,
like tennis shoes.
I think that's how you know
that you're like getting
to the point where you just
don't care what people think.
It's like,
I literally bought them in
like six different colors
and it's like all I wear.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause my feet hurts sometimes.
- [Ted] My feet hurts a lot, yeah.
- But I can't hear you though.
I have to wear heel.
I don't have to,
but people expect women to wear heels.
- I know.
- All the time, yeah.
- Are you doing that to yourselves
or is it us?
Us guys?
- I think a man invented them.
So, but,
and I think it was like back
in the day for like royalty wasn't it?
So they appeared taller like
for the Kings.
Wasn't it that like wear heels kind
of did I just make that up?
Are we playing the game BS?
- No.
- I feel like if we're
playing the game BS.
- But at least I'm not mansplaining.
why you got have to wear heels.
- I know.
I, know.
I don't have to.
Which is the point,
but I do wear like more comfy ones now.
I have platforms now.
How is Mary?
I love your wife so much.
- She loves you too.
And she--
- She's so great.
Will say that to you in person some day.
- [Kelly] How are y'all?
I love you as a couple.
- [Ted] Oh.
- Are y'all ever apart?
I feel like y'all are always together.
- We had a two week rule,
you know you and, but
that that's gone.
It's like she's,
she's gone tonight and we're distraught.
- You're like what am I gonna do?
- Yeah. It's not an ah.
It's like I've turned
helpless to be honest.
- It's a codependency it's awesome.